Creating a point light in 3js is simple enough and you can look at the
documentation page for more details. In this exercise the code is set up so
that the scene is lit by only ambient lighting. It's quite flat as you can see
and details lost. What I want you to do is turn off the ambient lighting and
turn on what I call a head light. Think of it as a miner's light, something you
put on your head to look around in the dark. Instead of a flat ambient light,
you have a light that is guaranteed to illuminate everything you see since it's
located where ever you are. If you search for the word headlight in the
code,you'll see where you need to modify things. There are two things you'll
need to do. The first is to add the proper type of light to the fill scene
method. Use the headlight variable which I've declared at the top of the code
for you. Declaring it at the top makes this variable usable in any of the
methods in the code. Make the headlight a full white color and intensity of
1.0. The second task is to make the light's position always match that of the
camera for every frame. If you look in the render method you'll see this code.
This method is called every time a new image is to be rendered. Don't worry
about the delta and the camera control calls. Leave those alone. The key line
here is the render objects render call. This call is what actually renders the
scene. What you want to do is to make the headlight's position math the
camera's position before rendering. By doing so, the headlight will then shine
on everything visible, bathing it with illumination. The surfaces then are not
all the same dull solid ambient color, but have some definition to them, which
looks more realistic. Both the light and the camera are derived from object 3D
so you can access the position of both of these in the same way.